- How do we know who we are?
How do we know where
we exist in our brain?
Our identity,
something that everybody
knows but can't define.
(dramatic instrumental music)
I spend much of my day trying to answer
these very, what used to
be philosophical questions,
which are now biological questions.
I am a cognitive neuroscientist
and I study the brain and all aspects
of self-awareness, deception,
and how people think about themselves.
- [Narrator] Our expert
cognitive neuroscientist
explores identity and
the mind with the help
of the new Hulu original series, Chance.
- In our initial studies,
we showed subjects
their own face, and what we discovered
is that when you look at yourself,
either in a picture or in a mirror,
the neurons in the right prefrontal cortex
get very, very excited
and they start firing
what we call action potentials.
When you remove that right hemisphere
or temporarily disrupt it,
people have a very difficult time
thinking about themselves or
reacting to their own face.
We know that anywhere
in that frontal cortex,
damage to those areas can cause
a very profound personality change.
- Jaclyn Blackstone, he struck you in
the face with a jack handle.
Shortly thereafter, you became aware
of a second personality, Jackie Black.
- [Jaclyn] She does things
that I don't want to do.
- I would best describe a neuroscientist
talking about dissociative
identity disorder
as skeptical.
We do know that it's an
often faked disorder.
On the other hand, someone who suffers
post-traumatic stress disorder often has
a related dissociative
identity disorder with them.
The person goes back
to the traumatic event.
(screaming)
One of the findings in neuroscience
is that whether you're faking
it or it's actually real,
your brain doesn't really
know the difference.
People who are feigning
DID can actually fool
the scanner into believing that
these are two different
personality states.
(dramatic instrumental music)
The self is very fluid and it shifts
from situation to situation.
It's very malleable,
and it's very adaptable.
- You haven't been
yourself for a long time.
- One of the discoveries in our lab
is how much people don't
know about themselves,
who they are, what they've done,
who they're going to become.
People are very inaccurate
when they evaluate themselves.
Ingrained in every human being
is some level of self-deception.
Why that is is that it's
actually pretty healthy
to not know who you are,
that the people who know
who they are tend to suffer
from clinical depression.
- [Woman] Look after yourself, Eldon.
- Having a self is maybe
the most precious gift
given to every human being,
that we can actually
think about who we are,
and I think that's what makes us human.
(dramatic instrumental music)